welcome everyone
I hope you enjoyed this presentation
we're gonna have some fun debugging
um on embella Linux so let me first
um introduce myself and work with
embedded for 25 plus year now
I'm located in Sao Paulo Brazil and I've
been working with my company for 12 plus
years now I do Consulting and training
for customers
um
in Brazil and also we have a few
customers in Europe and in U.S
I'm also an open source contributor
archive now I would say
um beautiful
and a few other open source projects you
can sorry follow me on Academy you can
find me there uh Twitter and also you
can
follow my blog Sergio perado.blog
so our agenda I'm gonna quickly
introduce this talk debugging
and I'm gonna talk about some
the most important techniques and tools
to debug any kind of software of course
our Focus here is embedded Linux
and I hope to have lots of Hands-On
during the presentation
um any bugs are intended for this
presentation
hopefully we don't have unintended books
like
um
well what is the bug right the bug is
the process often it's fine solving bugs
that's a horse softer harder
and I found that this topic is very
fascinating because this is something
that we usually don't learn right in
school
but that's something that we do almost
every day
um
so that's something that's kind of
improve over time right
um and one of the ideas of this
presentation is to
try to understand like there are several
different ways and techniques and
process to debug
there is one very common that is adding
print to the code
and when we start our career that's
something that we do but over time
um we learn other techniques that are
usually more productive
so let's let's talk about this in this
presentation
um
it's hard to say like try to find out a
good process for debugging software it's
like you are a detective right
and usually you are also the the one
that you're searching for right the
criminal
you are the criminal and detective at
the same time because you are searching
for bugs in the software that you wrote
but anyways
um usually I follow the the this process
to the book uh any kind of uh software
I first try to understand the problem
that's very important right
um let's say you are having a kind of
Ops or arcano Panic you need to
understand that you need to understand
what kind of pancake is you need to
understand how to analyze the kernels
message
so if you don't understand that
um it's going to be more difficult for
you right to find out the issue so
that's the first part and then the
second step would be try to reproduce
the problem
that is also very important because if
you cannot reproduce the problem
um how will you say that you solve it in
the end right so we need before you even
start to work you know the problem you
need to find out a way to reproduce it
sometimes it's very easy right like you
run a software in crashes so it's easy
to reproduce
but sometimes not that easy you might
like
have intermittent problems and then
you're gonna have to find a way to
reproduce the inter intent problem so
it's not sometimes it's not that easy
but that's an important part of the
debugging process
and the third step would be to identify
the root cause
so now you understand what is happening
uh the current is crashing
um now you can reproduce the problem
like if you write to this file then the
kind of crashes
and then now you're gonna try to find
out the root cause
that's usually what takes most of your
time right searching for the bug
as soon as you find the root cause then
it's a manual process of applying the
fix are the possible fix because
sometimes you don't know if that's the
correct fix sometimes it's a try and
everything
and if it fix it because you know how to
reproduce or if you cannot reproduce
anymore then you are in theory good to
go if you're not you're gonna get to get
back to the first stat and start again
so this is kind of a process right debug
any kind of problems in software
um also I usually classify software
problems in five categories
um you might find out another category
you know but usually you can take any
kind of bargain and classify one of
these five categories
crash problems that's when the software
just crashes
crash is a kind of uh unexpected
um
uh it stops execution right abruptly
um it might be because usually like
users user application crashes because
of a valid memory access then you have
the stackful segmentation for her but
you have you might have other reasons
for crashes like uh invalid instruction
the software try tried to execute any
valid instruction
um another kind of like a division by
zero on some architectures that will
crash the software and so on
uh the kernel might also crashed right
with a kind of panic for example
um lookups hangs another category of her
so the software just tanks when I when I
say you the software could be the kernel
in our like case we're talking about an
embellishment system where I have the
Linux kernel and then user space
applications
so
the kind of my Hang because of some bug
in the kernel or a user application
might also hang
so that's another type of error for
example let's say you have a much thread
application and because of some
kind of Deadlock issue in the
application right the application might
think likes and spreads waiting for the
mutex to be released by the other thread
and then
you have a Deadlock
um
large card implementation
um so any software it's a kind of system
right where you have inputs some kind of
processing in the output
um so this kind of error everything's
kind of working but the output's not
expected not what you expect
so it's a large problem or an
implementation problem
fourth type of error research leakage
so it leaks research for some reason the
most common research
that leaksi software usually is memory
especially if you are working with a
dynamic allocation right
you might have problems if you don't
have a kind of garbage collector that
stuff
but to my leak other resources for
example you open a file and forget to
close that file right if you stay in a
loop open a file without closing it then
you might end up with no file
descriptors for you because you are
leaking file descriptors they kind of
cannot allocate for you by the
scriptures anymore
last type of error in my five major
categories
is lack of performance or performance
issues so everything is working but
um you are using too much memory or too
much CPU
um of course this is very relative right
like you have a softer running on an
embedded Linux device with uh I don't
know
um
256 Megs of RAM
if you take the same software in runs in
a PC with
dozens of memory you might not have a
performance issue but if you have if you
run it on an Evidence device you might
um so usually the performance issue is
relative to the to the system that you
are running on the software
why not right you might really have a
kind of a problem
um in the application or in the kernel
that are causing the the usage of too
much pure memory or maybe energy
and so on
very good
and uh I also usually like say that we
have five tools or techniques
to to solve this kind of problems
um
I would say the first and probably the
most important tool is our brain
uh that means your acknowledge
not only can knowledge but also these
cues right
you need to understand and also know how
to apply that understanding
and that's important that's a tool
that's always or we should always keep
improving it
another technique very important to the
bug software is post-mortion analysis
it's a kind of technique where you do
analysis of some kind of information
that you extracted from the device
like logging you might strike the kernel
logs to see what's going on at the
currently space or it might distract
um a user space log let's say Journal D
or something else you might create dumps
from memory to analyze later
um for example you can generate a card
from an application that is crashing and
then do the analysis
tracing profiling is another technique
for debugging
and
adding print to the code it's in inside
that category so probably most most of
us know how to do Tracy
because when you add prints to the code
you are tracing the code which are all
messages
but the point here is that there are
several
um
that are that is an infrastructure in
the kernel and also several tools and
Frameworks in user space to trace
applications
without the need to add messages to the
application so that's important and I'm
gonna talk about this during this
presentation
um
another tool technique to the bug it's
the interactive
debugging
um like GDB so GDB is a tool that allows
us to
interactive the debugger software you
can stop the execution run the code line
by line and so on that's another way to
debug software
foreign
there are several I usually call it
Frameworks or debugging Frameworks to
debug software
one very known debug framework is called
wow grind to the bug memory related
problems
so those are tools that are created
so you can
debug better and a specific kind of
problem
um so my idea now is to show you
examples
on each one of these types of techniques
so we're gonna see problems
and how to apply those techniques for
those kind of problems
so I'm going to start so I'm going to go
so I'm going to start with postmorton
and then after that racing interact
debugging and debugging Frameworks let's
see how it goes I'm planning to do lots
of Hands-On here so we're gonna see my
terminal and hopefully everything will
work well
um we're going to have access to these
slides later everything that we're gonna
do here in the terminal it's only slides
of course you can write and if you want
but everything's in the slides you can
check it out later
um if you want but I think it's nice
instead of just saying that in the in
the slides just open the terminal and
play with it
so post multi-analysis is a kind of a
technique where you do the analysis
um after the bug happened
so it's uh you're gonna need some way to
collect information from the device
to analyze later this information can be
logs right
like logs from the kernel logs from a
user space application or it can be
terms from memory
that is a way to create for example a
dump from the Linux kernel
that is a group of tools called cadunt
and the assistant call from the current
call Key exec that allows you to do that
create a card then from the kernel but
we're not going
uh to talk about this we're gonna see
here
um
quarter in your news displays
application and also how to analyze uh
kenob's message
and I usually say that uh post-mort
analysis is a very good technique
to analyze crashes
and logic problems
that's usually very useful for those two
kind of uh problems
let's see here a few examples
we don't have much time to go over like
every detail but I hope
I'm gonna Focus here on the most
important things and I hope that will be
useful for you if later you want more
information about the specific parts of
this presentation you can just write me
um so a kind of Crash I have here this
board as you can see my camera I'm
running here um
I'm doing the both over Network so
everything is over Network
um
downloading the kernel and the device
tree and mounting the root file system
everything over the network
should be fast to the woods because it's
a very small system
all right let me know if the size of the
phone is not good for you or if you
cannot see it the first situation I'm
going to show you it's a kernel oops so
I'm gonna I added a few bugs okay in the
kernel and also in the in the files in
the in the user space
some user space applications
um so there is a bug in a candle if I
connect uh
uh USB stick
the kernel crashes nice so this is a
kind of crash
um
don't be afraid of cradle crashes
there are lots of useful information
here
um
since there are only numbers right but
no there are lots of useful information
here
so this is the beginning of the
cantaloupes message the second Ops
message
this is the beginning the first line you
can see the reason
of
the crash unable to handle new pointer
the heiference nice
as soon as
uh kind of developers convert everything
to rest we're not going to have this
problem anymore right but I'm not sure
that will happen
so at least
anyway
so there is a wild part there in the
software in the kernel that is causing
this
um
more useful information here
here we can see the location of the
program counter this kind of information
really depends on the architecture so if
you are running this on x86 or beeps or
RPC or any other that's this arm 32 bits
you might see different registers right
but the information will be there
so this is the program counter and this
is the location of the crash you have
the name of the function and you have
the index inside the function that
causes the crash you can use this to
find out the line of code that caused
the crash
here you also have the address
of a memory that causes the crash that's
basically the same thing as this
information here the address this is the
function plus index
and the address is the same thing
um and
below we have the back Trace
that's the
functions that were colored until the
crash so cut k-trad call it worker trade
at college process one work that call it
Hub event
going up to
here that crash it
so this might be useful for you to debug
like all of the functions that was that
were called
nice how can we debug this so to the
back this we need
the three things we need the the first
code of the Linus kernel we need tools
from the tool chain
there are two tools that you can use
here GDB and aggr to line
um and uh you need we need the the the
the kernel image in elf format with the
bugging symbols
I have here
um all of this
so this is the kernel source code
I have the Karen with the bugging
symbols here this is this VM Linux 5 is
the kernel image uh in elf format that's
not the image that we put
um but it is generated when you build a
kernel and here we can see that this L
file has the body symbols that means you
can convert those addresses
to symbols like line addresses
let's do this so one tool to do this is
um a to the R2 line
um you can see that I'm using my cross
compiler tool chain right you need to
use your cross compiler to change the to
change your user to build
the kernel
um
and uh I'm gonna pass here
Dash F to see the function I I what I
want to do is to convert
that addresses that address what is the
address here of the crash
here so I want to convert this address
to a line of code
so I take in the address of the program
counter
and then
I'm gonna pass
e the kernel image and the address oops
sorry
here we go so
now I have storage probe
that's the function where the question
happened the source code and the line so
now I can open this
right so then this file oops
1 1 8.
this is the line that crashes
and uh if you want to see why we can see
that is unusual Dev pointer
is new here and it was not initialized
so yeah I added that code there to crash
right
but you could see like how easy it was
to
um to find out the line of code that
caused the crash sometimes it's not that
easy to find the root cause that's two
different things one thing is to find
out the line of code that causes the
issue and the other thing is to find out
why that line is crashed in this case it
was kind of easy
but it might not be that easy right but
it's like it's better than just open the
Cardinal that's 30 million nights of
code and starting adding prints to it
much better
so this was a kind of example on doing
post-modal analysis in a kernel code
I want now to show another example on
doing this on an user space application
so I have here an application again
everything that I have done here in the
academy now it's in the slides right so
you can see all of the comments here
and you're gonna be able to refer to the
presentation later it's going to be on
YouTube so you can watch it later again
if you want to review this process
um
have another example here so I have this
asking application that is crashing
let's see if I can
check if you have any questions not oops
it's not boot look probably because I
forgot to remove the pen drive
and it's crashing every time it boots
couple of questions
um about the first question is I did
answer that question but you can add
your uh uh take on it as well the more
you test less you debug am I wrong that
is the first question
um
I wouldn't I would not say like the
Mario test the
um less bugs you have but I would say
the batteries are test coverage
then for sure less bugs you have in the
code because sometimes you test but you
test the wrong thing
um
or you not cover everything from this
author so
there are several ways that the stocks
not focus on
um
avoiding uh adding bugs to the code or
preventing from adding bugs to the code
right but uh like working with unit
tests and and doing
um tests before release I mean I mean
there are several different techniques
that you could apply to prevent from
adding bugs to the code it's impossible
to not add anybody to the code I mean uh
probably the only code that doesn't have
bugs decode that doesn't have any lines
but the more you cover your software
from the testing perspective the better
for sure would be yeah the quality of
the code yeah
so there is another question about uh I
think that material
that the image let me see what the
question is can we get training
materials such as source and images for
the steps that you are showing I think
um that's probably the question the
image yeah yeah there's actually this
talk is part of my training on debugging
and everything is open so I can provide
you with links so you can style this
material and try for yourself
um I'm using here a toilet export and
for you to run all of those Hands-On
you're gonna probably need
um this uh development board or add that
to I don't know has better ties or any
other maker words but I can I can share
with all of you if you want
um I'm gonna send
um
the the slides with the the links for my
training and then you yeah you think you
can uh you think you can share the link
to the
with a with his lights
yeah we can we can definitely share the
links yeah okay
um so you can just include it in the
slides and we'll share and the other
question is how uh how to debug issues
that are difficult to reproduce on
systems
um we have but uh something that's found
on a different system meaning a driver
works perfectly on one Hardware but it
doesn't on another
um socks and then also what if these are
remote yeah yeah in that case you can
just blame the harder right
um yeah that's a tricky question I mean
usually when I have this kind of
intermittent issues like you you can
reproduce this issue here but not there
or the the issue will only happen on
sunny days
um in that kind of situation what I try
to do is to create or write tools
to
um improve like make it easier for the
issue to happen
because you usually like you have to
play with Statistics right
so that is this issue in this protocol
that happens every like 20 messages that
you sent or something like this so with
some tools and automation you might want
to improve or increase the possibility
of the issue to happen
and then you leave the two running like
for several hours or maybe days
to create this kind of statistical data
like I ran my tool for three days and
then I got three times the issue
and then you have this data like we're
gonna work with this and then you you
work on fixes and keep it running R2
until you you cannot see the issue
anymore
and then after that you go to produce
with that fix and see if it's working I
mean it's
kind of tricky right to work with those
kind of intermittentary issues to try to
understand what is the root cause of the
problem
very good
um
so I want to show you now the
another
situation where we do post-mortar
analysis so this is an application that
is crashing
as I added this course
and how can we debug that so we could
start here at GDB session that could
also be effective but I'm gonna do it
post more to analysis so what I want to
do here is to
um create a coordinate of the
application according is a kind of a
snapshot of the application that crashes
so let's do that there is a tool call it
you limit
that makes it possible to configure the
limits of an application
like how many threads you can create how
many files you can open and that stuff
so one of the limits is the size of the
garden
and then you can
configure that with the dash C parameter
by default it's zero of course it
depends on your system on your
distribution for example
but if you don't change it by default
the configuration is zero so I want to
increase that to unlimited so that means
only limited sorry
for now I can create Unlimited
files
that might be a problem for embeddling
system because let's say the application
is running one gig of memory is using
one gig of memory that means the the
quadrant will be of that size so you
need a space to create that file in your
system
but I mean here in my specific case
this is no problem because um all of my
file system is over Network
so I I have an unlimited space to start
files
now I'm gonna run the application again
you're gonna see that the core was done
with
so that means now I have here a core
file
this file this is an L file but
basically a snapshot of the memory of
the process that crash
now I can take this file
and on my host machine analyze it
so let's do that
um
what I need to do that so here well
unbut my system with beautiful that's a
build system and to the to to analyze
the chord what I need is the source code
of the application I need my two chain
of course and I'm gonna use a GDB for
that
um and I also need the binary with the
bug in sivo
on beauty hoods I have everything under
outputs built
and the application so everything is
here I think my service is inside my
binary is inside a SRC so this is the
binary generated by Beauty World
with debugging symbols
and I have the source code here and the
binary so I can do everything
yeah so how to do this require the
analysis
I'm gonna start first of all I need a
card there so I'm gonna
get that file from the targets to the
host but since all my file system is
inside this directory here
so it's it's already on my machine
because I'm booting over networks this
is the root file system it's already on
my machine and uh
is your
I would say yeah this is the cord amp
so I'm gonna
copy this file
here
I need to add permeate to other
permissions to my user to this file
because by default it's
only by root
now I have the file here the core file
that was created on the device and I'm
gonna do a post mode analysis on the
host then I'm just going to open GDB
with this file so I started today with
the application
and record the dash C
ore
so what cdb will do is just stop like
show me the line of code the last line
of code that was executed that's the
line of code that caused the crash
here you can see they issue the problem
problem terminated with zigzag V that's
a sign that the kind of sent to the
application
because the application accessed an
invalid memory addresses and that's the
line of code that caused the crash
optipars line
217.
sorry there is one question probably the
lower to answer now is it possible to
specify where to save the column file
Jazz exactly it is possible there is a
file I'm not sure if I mentioned here
um
jazz is here so that is this proxy
scanner core pattern that you can use to
specify information about where you want
to generate this file the name of the
file and so on
uh I think the specifics of this
question is uh um they are running
application running on a Docker
container and would like to save the
code um in a volume shield with the host
I think that's kind of what you have on
your setup right now yeah
yeah that will not change the same thing
yeah
um
yeah so there is a nice feature from GDB
that I like that's the three modes
because it shows you a better view of
the source code so if you start GDP with
Dash Twi
you can see like a window with a source
code and that is nice right so here you
can see like the line that crash and
then and here you can also see the same
line
uh two one seven and another thing nice
about the quadrants that you can
re-inspect the memory because it's a
snapshot of the memory
so you can print stuff like I want to to
see what is the value of these options
pointer print options and then you can
see
and
not new so probably it was not that one
that caused the crash
you can print the value of the argument
point and inside this option pointer to
see if it's new and we can see it is
zero no that means that was the pointer
that caused the crash
uh we can actually actually print the
complete structure here options
uh print if I have for instance this
pointer I can see the complete content
of the structure so as you can see we
really have access to the content of the
memory
and I can do a back Trace
um to see like main College this
function this function crash I can go to
main like frame one and go to Main and
then I can see the the call
to that function that crashes so I
really can inspect the software of
course I cannot run the software here
right that's what that's why you're
doing like it's a post-mortar analysis
you are not doing an interactive
debugging session I'm gonna do that in a
few
um moments but not now so this is a
post-morting analysis it's very useful
for cases where you don't have access to
the device
uh you asked someone can you please just
like run these comments generate a card
up and send it to me then I can analyze
here
that might be very useful
what there is one question about a GDB
shows up sometimes GDB shows optimized
out why yeah I'm going to post it for
everybody
yeah that's
that's because
um when you
when you compile the software with
optimizations flags
the
compiler will optimize the code that
means the compiler might remove lines of
code because these things doesn't need
to run or might
reorder some instructions to improve
let's say the the speed of software or
the size
so
if you compile the software with any
kind of optimization Flags you might
have problems
um
in that case what I usually recommend
try to debug with optimization on
because that's what it is running right
on your production system but if that's
causing you problems like you really
want to see this or that and the
compiler optimizes that then you're
gonna have to turn off the optimizations
or decrease the optimization level
usually on on GCC so if you open the GCC
one page you're gonna see those Dash oh
um
options this is
nowadays the recommended flag to build a
software with a same set of optimization
level that doesn't impact debugging the
dash OG
but you might build a software with like
Dash or three for example
or Dash OS that improves the size of the
binary and that might impact debugging
it's a trade-off
so there is another question can we
detect a memory leakage using GDB like
Val grind GDB
uh and wall grind probably
um I never use a GDB to debug the leaks
um
I'm gonna show you in a in a few slides
how to do that with flower grind I felt
that most of the time you're gonna
I'm gonna use raw power grind for that
kind of uh
problems
um the trade-off is for grind we run the
software slowly
but let me get there because I'm going
to talk about war grinds and then you
might ask again if that doesn't answer
your question
but so we saw a few examples on doing
um
on debugging
using this post-mortar analysis
um I'm not sure how we are on the tiny
eyes
we are kind of in the head in the middle
of the presentation so let me let me
know if I should go faster or not but
hopefully you are enjoying um tracing
Trace is another technique
to debug software
it's a kind of a specialized
type of logging right Tracy enables you
to trace the execution of the software
and also
um
do some kind of
runtime analysis
you can measure the executional
functions you can measure latencies
because you are tracing like all
functions and that stuff
that are different techniques in
Frameworks to implement tracing
there are static there are two kind of
like when you do Tracy you add the trace
points in the code
when you add a print to the code you are
doing a static you are adding aesthetic
Tracy point to the code
and in the Linux kernel for example
there are Frameworks to do Dynamic
tracing that means you can dynamically
at runtime not at build build time at
runtime you can add Trace points in
Canary space and in user space
that's very nice
and uh
Trace is very useful for a different
kind of problems but when you want to
measure performance it helps when you
want to measure latency it also helps
lookups the software is just locking up
like
some reason
um
Tracy might help because you can
identify like the function that frees
the execution
I want to show you here a few examples
so at Canary space
that is a nice framework
call it f Trace
you can do everything with average
so I've traced the infrastructure in the
kernel for tracing
and hitting this example I'm tracing an
application that is taking a while to
execute I'm going to show you like what
it is using then I'm going to show the
bug so
two
to use f Trace what you have to do is
go to the kernel like let me open here
the kernel configuration menu and then
you go to this very nice menu called it
kind of hacking
and then there are several nice features
there
um if you have some time go there and
see and then there is this menu tracers
if you enable tracers you're gonna
enable apptrace and then there you have
several different traces to trace the
execution
of building looks care no not only gonna
look scary but also usually space
applications
and then if you enable that
you're gonna have a
the basic interface to have traces a
file system and then you can just mount
it
Trace FS usually we mounted these
directory Cisco no tracing and then
we're gonna see there are several files
to enable tracing I'm going to show you
a quick example of how that works
so we have here for example this file
called available tracers
and those are the traces that I enable
for this kernel and then I'm gonna
enable this one function graph Tracer
it's going to show me all of the
functions executed at the counter space
in a graph View
so to enable that I have to write the
name of the Tracer so this current
Tracer file
now it's enabled now what is happening
the kernel is Tracy itself and right
into a
buffering memory
um
that we can
see
with this Trace type file
so here what we are seeing is all of the
kind of functions being executed
this might be very useful because you
don't need like to to try to print to
the code like I'm executing this
function now I'm executing this function
because it's everything here you don't
need to do anything and there are
several files here because it's a lot of
information but you can filter by
process you can filter by function by
subsystem by events so you can really
play a lot with this
and here is an example of using F Trace
to debug an application that is taking a
lot to execute so
I added a bow to the core quote to the
kernel code where if you try to
Blink a LED like enabling
um turning on an LED it's taking four
seconds
usually it doesn't take four seconds
right to Blink an LED so that is
something
going on here
then I mounted F Trace then here I'm
using a command call it tracemd this is
a comma to make it easier to use f Trace
because I could write directly to those
files but I would need to write to
several files to do this tracing and
Tracey Med would just do that for me
I'm asking tracemd
to do a function graph tracing of this
comment
and then it will run the comment it will
trace the kernel and generate a debt
file for me
with all of the functions executed by
the kernel
and then I can take this
um Trace file and ask Tracey midi to
generate a report for me to parse it and
then show me
in a human readable way
and then I'm just redirecting that to a
log and then cats in the log
and then
I'm gonna see all of the kernel
functions executed when I run that
comment
and here I can see if I now do some
analysis on this I can see that this
function called this function that call
it is Ms lip function that took four
seconds
to run so I can see here the cause
of
that delay in the execution and any
sleep call inside this function
I didn't have to do anything just enable
F Trace generate the the tracing and
then do some analysis on the data
I can do that also with a graphical tool
call it kernel shark that's very nice
um so if for those that like graphical
applications I mean
there are some nice graphs here about
few usage and the functions that were
called you have the same information
here but
you can filter do that stuff that you
can do with graphical applications
if you want to learn more about F Trace
I would recommend
um
Steven stocks those are always very
funny so just go to YouTube
and search for f Trace you're gonna
for sure find several talks about Steven
and we're gonna have some fun with
tracing the kernel with abstracts
I have a few questions would you like to
take them now
um
yeah yeah let's do it why not it's about
if it's about yeah this stuff okay
so sometimes you get core filed from
production with optimized values on
error line there is no way to reproduce
this then what to do
right
um
well if you have a
Accord dump it's a snapshot of the
memory
and
if the software that you run
um was compiled in some kind of
optimization level
um where you cannot really like match
the line of code
with a memory with the the memory
addresses that is really not much you
can do but try to reproduce the problem
later and generate another Cardon with
the application without optimizations
lab or at least I I'm not sure I I don't
know how you would debug in this kind of
situation right it's it's always a
trade-off right the like
um
the if you want to improve security
usually you decrease the bugability and
if you want to improve research usage
usually you you decrease the level of
the ability you have
it's harder to debug
and that is not much you can do right
sometimes you try to find a good balance
between between those
but usually as far as my knowledge goes
that is not much you can do but try to
reproduce the problem later
with a different level of optimization
where you can't really debug that that
software
so the second question is GDB is for
user space only can we debug
let's do it in a moment okay we'll do
that so after commercials
can well grind catch Dynamic Library
memory leaks
uh yes so far grind will basically
um
simulate the software
and
if the Bleak is happening at the mem at
the library level and flower greens will
be able to see that now
if Walgreen will be able to find out the
symbols from the library that's causing
the leak then that depends on if you
have the library with the bugging
symbols installed on the target
um I'm gonna also talk a little bit
about that on the hour I thought
so I think the other question we have is
it's worth mentioning that Ubuntu and
com other distros have tracing support
usually enabled yes some of them do uh
disclose
um you can just check those and if not
you have to enable I think most of them
now have that enabled uh is it possible
to filter the output of f Trace to
follow single device driver that is
running on the system
how does that work
um usually you don't I mean you can
filter you can do different kinds of
future you can filter by function so you
can just say I want to I I want to just
see only those functions I want those
five functions on that
so yes like if you just want to debugger
driver you can filter by their Solutions
and you can also filter by module so you
have a Dotsy file that's a module and
then you can filter by that you can
enable I wanted to see just the
functions from that kernel driver that
dot C file
so so yes in my example I have done the
debug at the process level so I asked
the 370 to debug that user space
application
um so
in this Trace I have all of the
functions call it at the kernel level
um
from this process ID
that's what that was the filter that was
created here by tracemd but yeah you can
change as I mentioned by function by
file by subsystem
so it's yeah pretty much flexible
I think we have one more question here
do we have any limitation or
disadvantages of Val grind
yes vowel grind will run the software
like five times over
uh because
it will vulnerize the way it works to
capture problems in memory
the way it works is that it will emulate
the software
it's kind of like off kirimo it will
emulate the software your application
that it has like the implementation of
syntax syntax CPUs inside of it
and that means if the software will run
pretty much longer so
if we don't care about that usually when
you are debugging like memory
allocations or deadlocks
you might not care about the speed of
the execution execution speed of the
application but sometimes you might care
about that
sometimes the the execution is important
that the speed and if you want to really
execute the application not emulate the
application and then you might want to
use other tools
for
to debug in a specific problem
and then bow right might not be the
right tool for you
you just need to be aware of that the
software will run slower
that's the trade-off
so
just two more questions
um there are some scenarios where
drivers don't care about function return
values and so can silently fail how does
one catch that if the silent failure
bites the much after it actually
happened
not sure if I follow the question so
you have a function that doesn't have a
return
and if it fails
maybe it's a problem in the design of
the function because it doesn't have a
returning Theory it it doesn't want to
report a failure
uh so I'm not sure if I understood
that question can you rephrase that
return values are not checked in some
cases
oh okay so the returning values are not
checked so the function has returned
values but they are not checked
and the question is how to debug that
yes I think that that is the question so
essentially I think the question is
about silent failures meaning you do not
have a good cookie crumbs as you're
going by and trying to debug the problem
you don't have a
um you don't always know
um you don't have enough information to
say this is what could have happened
I would say the best tool for that is
GDB
um
like doing until the internet because
you don't you cannot collect information
you don't have information it's just
failing right that's in the the category
of logic problems where the software
just fail but you don't have much
information about it so I will just run
step by step the code
to try to get to the function that is
failing but not like providing any
feedback
right and then in some cases if you if
the problem goes away GDB sometimes you
cannot reproduce the problem the problem
is not reproducible through GDB you have
to find other ways to uh figure out
what's happening
right GDP is useful I would think that
in cases where uh for analysis it's
useful sometimes it's not always useful
useful to reproduce the problem I think
that's that would be accurate to say
yeah yeah yeah I would agree
and so I think uh through I hopefully
that answered your question if not come
back to us I have couple of more
questions is this okay two ask looks
like they have a couple of more
questions depending how is it going in
terms of do you want to differ these
questions maybe I could I could move it
yeah move on a little bit and then okay
okay sounds good yeah so we'll get back
to your questions just hang on yeah
good so here I have a few more examples
on users on Tracy button user space
Tracy
um there are two tools that I like to
use at the user Space level for tracing
uh one of them actually two S3 study
Trace s Trace is a two to three system
calls early Trace is a two to trace
Library codes
and those tools are usually very like
it's
it's easy to use and it's very helpful
so it's a tool that can help you to
understand what a binary is doing
to understand the result of the
execution of a binary
um in this kind of situation that the
question like the you run a specific
software and then it just fails but it
don't provide you any feedback maybe as
Trace can help you on that because as
Tracer is going to show you all the
system calls and then you can see like
for example let's say an application
tries to open a configuration file the
configuration file is not there then it
fails but it doesn't show you any
message
so with that stress you can see that
right so it's very very useful here I
have an example with this
match Cat application I just added a bug
there you run adcat so then it fails
couldn't set up listening sockets for
some reason you cannot
listen to this
TCP ports and then if you run it as
Trace you're gonna see all system calls
executed
um and then if you go down like from the
the the bottom up then you can see the
message if you go up you can see the
error
so this system called bind returners bad
address and then you got this message
then you here you can see that the bind
called file failed and if you look at
the interface for the buying call you're
gonna see that this parameter is missing
you are passing new here but should not
be new
so we have now a good indication of why
the software is failing so there is a
bug in the software that is passing the
wrong argument to the buying call
just by running ashtrays you could have
this kind of feedback right without
opening any source code then you don't
need source code for that because it's
just capturing the system calls parsing
that and showing you the name of the
system call the parameters and the
return
you can have the same thing with L Trace
but electric is for Library calls
um
yeah those are two very nice tools
another example here I'm not going to do
this at the terminal
um because it might take a while and I
want to cover the last part GDB stuff
um
so here I'm using uh care infrastructure
called geoprobe or usually space probe
to probe user space applications because
asteroids and electrics can help you
debug Trace usually space applications
but you cannot use asterisk analytres to
trace the functions from the application
itself only the assistant calls in
library calls
if you want to trace the functions from
the application itself you can use upro
products
and there are a few tools and scripts
that makes it easier to use upro because
not that easy to use it one tool that I
feel it's very easy to use is perf
so here I have uh an example that I
created with perf
to trace this
ath2
in the first comment here I am adding
the trace points so I have a loop where
I'm collecting all Trace points from
this software and then enabling those
Trace points that means I'm taking all
of the functions
from this binary and adding as Trace
point to the kernel so when I run the
software if I have those Trace points
enabled the kernel will
uh let me know
that's the idea here so I'm enabling the
trace of all of the functions inside
this software with this common line here
I can see this if I run
Earth probe list I can see all of the
probes that I created at the trace point
that I added and then I can use the perf
record to run the application
and
capture all of those Trace points
the result of this will be a
perv.data file with the
result of tracing that application that
means all of the functions call it from
the application
is going to be inside that file
then I can use another command from perf
perv script
to parse that then I can see all of the
functions that was called
I mean there are lots of different
things that I could talk about perf here
you can create a graph a back trace and
all that stuff but just a simple example
and you can there are lots of things to
explore here you can yeah just try perf
it's a very nice tool not only for
profiling but also for for tracing
so those are two kind of techniques that
I usually use for tracing user space
applications
let's talk now about interactive
debugging
um that's one of the main like
techniques that we use for debugging
right and nowadays still GDB is our
default tool for that so I want to show
you
um two examples of interactive debugging
one that the current space there was a
question there someone asking can I use
udb other counter space yes you can
let's see it and one at the user Space
level the point here is that you need
the
like a client server architecture
because you have the source code the
tools the binary debugging cables in
your host Machining in your target
machine that's your device you have only
yours the software running
so what you need is a GDB server running
on the target device
communicate with a client on your host
machine
receiving comments from the client and
execution is executing
the instructions on the target
so the client will just say like add a
big point to this address run the next
line of code and that's the
and the server will just execute that
so
that's how it works
and it happens that the kernel has this
kind of a server implementation let's
call it kgdb so if you enable Cajun
being the character
you you're going to enable configure hdb
and a driver for communicating with the
kgd
we usually use the serial port for that
um I want to show you how this works now
so the first thing is to set up the the
infrastructure of communication and the
things I'm using
uh the serial part for the console so
here I'm connected over the Zero part I
cannot just reuse it for GDB so what I
usually do is I use a an agent
there to act as a kind of proxy for
communicating over the serial ports
there is one agent provided by the
community call it Asian production
I think it's inside kernel.org uh
server and it's a very simple
application that will act as a peroxide
so you run it
uh telling the serial parts of the
device and to TCP Parts the first one is
for the console the second one is for
GDB so every communication will pass
through this proxy that will distribute
the messages so if it's a GDB message it
goes to GDP if it's a console message it
goes to the console part
foreign
part for the console then you don't need
this okay
but I I am so I'm gonna use it so I
started the proxy now I'm gonna set up I
have to start a telnet connection
in the first part
you can see now that I'm connected I'm
gonna reboot here the device so
I'm the console but
overtonet
now I have this infrastructure setup
working I have the kernel with k2db
enabled now now what I can do is just
um
put the kernel in the buggy mode
I can do it that at boot time or at
runtime I'm gonna do at runtime I
created here a the small share script to
do that for me but I will show you
so this is the show script I need just
to set up the parameter for the
communication that's the serial part and
then use this sysrq
comment
to put the Canada bug mode
so if I run this
now the can is in debug mode it is
basically waiting everything is like
freeze it
now I can connect to the kernel over to
the
now I'll go to my
kind of search code on my host machine
I can start a GDP session
using the kernel
in L format the VM Linux image I'm going
to also use the 2E mode
for a better visualization
now what I have to do
connect to the device
so there is a common in GDB
targets
remote
what I want to do is to connect to my
localhost to the proxy that you send a
message to the device
so this part is that's departed for GDB
now I'm connected to the kernel
so now I can put any breakpoints
anywhere in the Cardinal including inter
service routines and debug the kernel
um I'm gonna debug this problem here so
let me just get one of the functions
this one so I'm gonna put Drake function
so I added a breakpoint to a function
inside the LED framework LED framework
from the kernel then I'm gonna ask you
should be to continue the execution you
can see here on the console that this
equation is
Frozen nothing's happened here
but I can go here continue
now that kernel is a cutie so if I go
there it's executing I'm controlling the
execution of the kernel
so
now I'm gonna write to the LED file
um let me click the command here this
one
and uh
and we're gonna see what's going to
happen so on
is garbage that I see here it's coming
from GDB
now if I go to
to GDB and then stop it at that function
that I added the brake punch and then I
can run the kernel code
step by step next next next I can do a
back Trace
I can do everything I want at Canary
space
so yes you can do interactive debugging
out the limit kernel with GDP it might
take a while for you to create this
infrastructure
but for complicated problems that might
be
very very helpful
to finish this interactive topic I want
to just quickly show
interactive debugging at the user Space
level
so I have here another situation
this one so
three
is hanging
so I have here a problem with the three
comments it is hanging I want to debug
it I could trace that would be one
option
um
I could add prints to the code to see
what's happening but I mean let's do it
with GDB how we can debug this with GDB
again it's a client server
architecture so I need to start a server
on the Target and run the client on the
host
and that is a common GDB server for that
so you do the server and then you you
say like the connection
and the comment
so I'm asking GDP server please
open
apart
one two three four to debug these three
slash VAR command and it's there waiting
for a connection then now I go
um
what is this okay I'll close it now I go
to the source code of the application
build
free
this is the search code so I need the
search code of the application I need
the two chain GDB from my tool chain and
I need the application with debugging
symbols
that's what I need then I start GDB
with my application
I'm gonna use three modes because it's
nice
so I open the application with you today
now I connect to the Target to connect
to the Target Target remote
now I'm will connect to the IP address
of the Target that in my case is so I'm
doing this
um so we're solving the kernel that I
use the setup part to transfer the
communication now I'm using an ethernet
connection so it's Network here so I
will use the IP address of the device
and that part that I use it there
now unconnected
it is stopped at the first line of the
code and since I didn't load the symbols
from libraries I cannot see like the
search here
but I don't care about this I just want
to put a break at the main function
break Main and then continue the
execution and now I'm debugging the
software so I can run it line by line
since it is hanging I can just continue
the execution
wait a few seconds
Ctrl C to stop it and then we can see
the line that is hanging
there is a call on there that should not
be there
foreign
I want to finish the presentation so
just a few more slides and then we can
open for questions and to the end of the
presentation
um
so to finish
debugging framework so I
that's the name that I
give for this kind of tools
it's not formal and when you create a
tool to debug some kind of problem like
you create an infrastructure
to debug that so uh there are several
debugging Frameworks and looks kernel to
the bug memory leaks to the bug
hangs lookups in the kernel
that our Frameworks at the user Space
level wow grind is one of them
so a few examples the kernel has let's
say you run a command and the kernel
just like it's freezing it's not it's a
good thing like it's hanging
um the kernel has little cup detectors
that can attack most of the situations
where it could just hang at counter
space
if you enable that that's usually not
really recommended for production
systems because it adds some overhead
but for debugging
you can enable it no problem and then
when you run something that hangs that
counter space
um after a few seconds usually 30
seconds third something you're gonna see
a kind of Ops
and it's a kind of Ops like any other
kind of Ops you're gonna see the problem
solve to look up you're gonna see the
pro the counter the function that uh
hanged you can take this information
and then with the Linux kernel source
code and there are two chain you can
find out the line of code
that's causing the
the hang
this is using log range so I have a
problem that in this common CPU load
and I have a problem with memory leaks
and I want to debug that so I added file
grind to the system and I want uh
valgrind to solve symbols for me so I
also updated the the program with the
buggy symbols
if you don't do that while grind is
still able to find the issue but it is
not able to solve symbols so you do not
say to you like which line of code that
allocated memory that was not
deallocated
but it still works if you have these
possibilities better to update the
binary with the bike receivables to run
it with long range and then you run
vowel grind
there are a few parameters there I
usually use this one for memory leaks
leak Shack equal Foo and the program
then
you leave the program running for some
time
you close it and then for grind us
generate a report for you
as soon as it is finished and then
you're gonna see like information about
the leaks so in this case I definitely
lost that means I allocated and didn't
allocate anywhere
nine times
this size here
36k
of RAM and then it generates
back Trace from the leaks
so this function do start call it the
principle that called malloc and this my
lock
was not
free
and if you open this you you're gonna
see
uh
the root cause of the leak
so if you run my grind with binary
debugging symbols you're gonna see this
kind of information that is very useful
source code and lines of code
if you don't you're gonna have to solve
the symbols
on the rows host you can do that
um
very good so
my conclusion here to open four
questions
is
um
when you start our career it's very
common for us to use only one technique
for the bug in that setting prints to
the code and when I say print add in
print the code maybe you are not even
adding prints to the code but like you
are you instrument the code somehow
right sometimes you don't have a way to
see a print so you blink an LED right so
you use an LED as a way to provide your
feedback and then you you do this
interactively right like you you you
change the code like if I pass it I'm
gonna blink this led
the fact that
uh
like instrument in the code
it's only one technique
and we need to understand
and most of the times
try to identify the best approach for
the best situation for the best problem
so
for those that are starting try to learn
more about all of those tools
for those that are not Titan like me I'm
learning every day about new tools
things are always improving and I'm
always learning about new techniques and
tools
and that's very important to try to
always improve the way we do things to
be more productive so
this light shows like for that kind of
problem we might have different
options or
um and the specific technique might be
better
just as a simple example interactivity
bug is very bad for performance analysis
because it might probably impact
the performance of the system if you run
it step by step line by line
so it's not good for that specific case
depends on the situation
uh you might like when you instrument
the code you might change the behavior
the simplest fact that you either print
to the code you you will change the
execution time and that might hide
problems
so Tracy for example might not be good
in some situations
so yeah my point here
is exactly that there are seven
different techniques and tools I show
you a few of them during the
presentation
try to explore them
uh we really just scratched the surface
there are lots of stuff I mean this
materials from my three-day training on
this talk
and I could really turn this into a
five-day training if I want
so there are lots of stuff to talk about
debugging and tracing and performance
analysis only nukes
so I hope all of this was helpful
um let me open for questions
and to the end of the presentation now
okay so let's see
um I'll start with the question in the Q
a box how can we extract the trace log
in case of cardinal panic when the
system
gets stuck
good question so the kernel has a
feature
uh uh to persist
a feature called P star
to persist
logs
um
if you want that you might want to have
a look
store
so this is a framework
that you can use to persist kernelogues
um to persist F Trace buffers
to analyze later it has this kind of
architecture where you can Define the
um the
[Music]
the place that you want to start is
usually of course
it is a persistent storage device like a
flash device but you might also want to
use memory so if you have a kind of a
soft reset
you can for example on iron you go to
the device tree you reserve a part of
the memory for for a p star and then uh
that part of the memory will be used to
persist logging and and then if you have
a soft reset let's say a kind of panic
with a reboot the next reboot you are
able to collect the the canops message
from the previous
boot
so have a look at this time
there is one question that might be if
this could be the very last question
probably sometimes GDB
um that crease shows corrupt stack frame
y
um again some kind of uh weird
optimization during done by by the
compiler
uh
you might have for example security
Flags enabled when you compile the
software
and this secured Flags might add some
specific
logic to handle the stack frames
and that might confuse GDB that's the
whole point because you don't want to
see the stack
um
so that might be one of the reasons
modernizations or security flags that
was enabled when the software was
compiled a few reasons that might cause
those corrupted
frames
foreign
okay
last question
um Candice how are we doing on time
um we have two minutes left yep we're
good okay
um how to debug corrupted kernel memory
while JTAG probe watchpoint support is
not available
can you repeat please
um yes how to debug corrupted kernel
memory while JTAG probe watch Point
support is not available
hmm
the kernel has a
the only way I know
to to debug in this situation is is by
using a feature from the kernel called
kdb
so kdb is a beauty debugger in the
landscape it's not related to kgdb so it
doesn't use it a bit it's a beauty a
beauty in the burger
um that you can use to debug at the
assembly or Machine level
so you can enable kdb and
as soon as I have some kind of Crash it
will pop up a kdb prompt so we can debug
memory you can really manipulate
everything like in memory process
everything
um so if the you are the problem that
you're having is not
doesn't impact the behavior of kdb then
you can use it to debug this kind of
situation
that's the only way I see if you don't
have the JTAG for that
so
so I one last question about
being able to debug threads can we can
you debug each kernel thread
independently not each CPU but each
thread I'm saying you're thinking kernel
thread I'm thinking it's not a CPU
thread
a candle thread
right
um yes I mean yes you can
um as soon as you attach it to the
to kgdb
you can add breakpoints to specific
threads to symbols from threads
um
and debug it
so I have never had problems with that I
yeah you can as you can do at usually
Space level you can also do at the
current Space level version
what I found impressive is that you can
even do it interrupt service routine so
at the interrupt context
you can you can debug and run the code
step by step so you can do that at the
interrupt constant for sure you can do
that that uh
level
right I think that's all we have
um as for questions
thanks thank you
um for doing this session lots of good
questions
Candice back to you perfect thank you
Sergio and Sushi over your time today
and thank you everyone for joining us as
a reminder this recording will be on the
Linux foundation's YouTube page later
today and a copy of the presentation
slides will be added to the Linux
foundation's website we hope you join us
for future mentorship sessions have a
wonderful day